thank you very much and uh thank you to
the organizers uh thomas and frederick
for
um inviting me to present this um
so this is a sort of slightly uh
esoteric talk in the sense that i think
if you're not interested in the marginal
dag models then uh you might not find it
as interesting as i do
but
uh
my aim was to sort of
help to try and bridge a few gaps by
introducing some concepts that are used
in the proof that might be of interest
to
quantum physicists and statisticians who
haven't come across them before
so
let me just briefly introduce the
problem
so hopefully
by now you've got the idea about what a
dag model is
um so we have here a graph over four
variables
and one of them is assumed to be latent
this h here
and
the question we might ask is whether
there is some
other directed acyclic graph model which
is distributionally equivalent to the
this one over the three observed
variables x y and z
and in this case it's very easy to see
there is we can just uh have the edge
point from x to y
and
just set h to be equal to x so x will
tell x what it's supposed to do and it
will give y exactly the information it
needs to respond to x and therefore
these two models are identical
on the other hand this is another model
which is known very well not to be
equivalent to a dag
but the first level just because the
conditional independences can't be
explained by any dag model right so you
can't have w jointly independent of y
and z and z jointly independent of w and
x
and only those independences in any
diagonal
so this is um sort of a contrast between
some models which can be represented as
dags without any hidden variables and
some which cannot
so the question is
which models can be represented as
dags without any hidden variables and
which can't
okay so
the background on studying this problem
is is very long so i won't go into the
details
so the important thing is because we're
often using these dags as causal models
we're not going to want to assume that
we have observed everything it's very
likely we will not so you need to posit
the possibility of there being latent
variables
um and that's why we consider these
models
and there's the problem of finding the
constraints in these models has a long
history so uh several other people in
this list are in the room so jamie
thomas and uh
uh jin are all here and uh there's
a sort of even longer actually
literature on finding inequality
constraints because bell did this before
anyone had come up with the idea of a
dag model
so he didn't draw this picture um it's
sort of been imposed afterwards
and
obviously this was followed up by
closer hotel who developed the chsh
inequality
um and then independently of that perl
introduced the instrumental inequality
which gives an inequality over the
observed variables on this graph here
which is expanded by bonnet using
computational algebra
and then there's been a whole series of
other papers on this topic including
many that aren't mentioned here and have
already been presented
and then most recently
of course ellie
rob and
tobias fritz have a paper on what's
called the inflation technique and it
was shown to be complete in the sense
that any distribution which is not in
the model
um can be refuted if you take a large
enough inflation and look at the
constraints
so i should just emphasize that all the
hidden variables i use will be classical
so there's nothing excitingly quantum
going on
okay so we understand quite a lot about
the marginal dag model because of all
those papers
so we know that there are three kinds of
constraints you can get
on a model where you don't make any
assumption about what the hidden
variables are
the first are conditional independences
and you can only observe them if there's
a conditional independence in the
original model
where all the variables are observed
and then you get these things called
nested conditional independences which
i'll show you in a second
which are also now quite well understood
um
and we know that for example if you
combine just these two constraints that
is defines the model up to its dimension
so we know there's no other equality
constraints beyond these two at least if
all the observed variables are discrete
and then on top of this we get the
inequalities which i think is by far the
least well understood
of these
three
possibilities
and
uh so let me let me give you a quick
example
so this graph has all three kinds of
constraints
so first of all you might notice that w
is
d separated from t so i'm not going to
define the separation because uh the
outer did it very nicely earlier but the
point is there's uh two paths from w to
t one of which goes through x and on
which x is a non-collider
the other which goes through x as a
collider but then has y as a collider so
as long as we don't condition on y
then that path will also be blocked and
therefore we get this d separation
relation here
then there's also a nested constraint
because if we
do this identifiable intervention so we
sort of get rid of this edge by dividing
by this
observable conditional distribution
we get this new model
and now
you notice that w is now d separated
from y
because we've deleted this path
and before it wasn't right because if i
condition on uh if i don't condition on
either x or t then this part's open but
if i do condition on x or t then i'm
going to open up this this path here or
the collider x
okay so this was not visible before but
now that we see there is a constraint
which corresponds to the fact there's no
edge from w to y
and then finally
you can also see that this is now the
bell graph
so we get the um the inequality that's
associated with that the chsh or
tyrson's inequality if it's a quantum
variable
okay and the aim today is to show
this main result
which is that if you have
a dag
over latent and observed variables and
then you marginalize out the latent
variables
then the model that you get which we
call the marginal model which i'll
define formula in a sec is the same as
the marginal model for some dag over
just the observed variables
if and only if there are no non-trivial
inequality constraints implied by g
so what do i mean by non-trivial
obviously probabilities have to be
non-negative
um so that is a trivial inequality
but there are also trivial inequalities
you get just by considering marginals of
dax right so
if you can observe a marginal and that
gives you some inequalities then they
don't count
so it has to be some inequalities that
are over and above what are directly
implied by the equality constraints that
you have
that's what i mean by a non-trivial
inequality
so
why do we care about this question um
well so originally uh
richard was asking me about when when
it's the case that an mdag is uh
distributionally equivalent to some dag
and he was interested because
in semi-parametric efficiency theory
it's very useful to know what the
tangent space of a dag is that sorry
every model is and if it's equivalent to
a dag then that's really well understood
and then we had a conversation with
ellie and he conjectured that basically
that would be true if and only if there
weren't any inequality constraints
and i was like i can't believe i didn't
think of this conjecture before
but thank you um and i i will now try
and prove this and
i believe that's what i've now done so
this is this is a completely new talk so
there may well be mistakes and um i'm
very grateful if you uh wish to point
any out
okay any questions at this point
okay excellent
so hopefully this slide is slightly
superfluous now
so direct acyclic graph is just a graph
with directed edges where there's no
directed cycle this is an example
and we say that a distribution is in the
model for a dag if each variable is a
measurable function of its parents i.e
the things that are pointing into it and
some independent noise and it's
equivalent to say that these
independences hold for each of the
vertices in the graph
okay
an endag
is obtained from a dag
by marginalizing so we use an operation
called latent projection
which again i'm not going to define but
it does something like this so if you
start with this graph over on the left
where now i've made the h's
be latent
then what i'm going to do is if i have a
latent like h1 here and it's got a
directed path to
say k observed vertices then i'm going
to put in a k hyper edge between those
guys
so i replace
the latent with this uh sort of triple
hyper edge here
and then if there's a
a directed path that goes through a
latent so for example t h2 to z
i'm going to replace that with just a
directed edge that's observable
okay and this
one can show preserves the model
precisely right so there's no difference
between the marginal model over this
uh sorry there's no difference between
the margin of the model over this graph
and the marginal model over this mdac
yes you're allowing the state spaces to
be argued
so just to repeat yeah so we are
allowing the state spaces of h1 h2 and
h3 to be arbitrary so it's not true if
we restrict those to to have a finite
cardinality necessarily
okay and uh we represent this by what we
call an mdag
so an mdag is a dag which is the blue
edges here
and then also we have a simplicial
complex which represents the the latent
structure
so
the idea is here i've i've just
represented the maximal facets of that
bi-directed
uh of that simplicial complex on the
graph so they are x y z and z w
and of course
t also has to be in the simplicial
complex but i'm not going to draw that
on because it's not interesting right
that's the only
variable in in a facet
okay
yeah can you just clarify real quick
exactly what assumptions you're making
on the hidden variables and the observed
variables are a continuous discrete
anything about the state spaces so the
yes good question so the observed
variables are discrete finite discrete
and the uh hidden variables are
arbitrary although one can show that
they they can also be assumed to be fine
and discreet um thanks to
various people's results
right okay and then we have this other
there's another question yes
no it's just really is it is it is there
an obvious reason that's going to be
simplex that i'm just not is the first
time i've ever seen it you say it's a
simple complex is it obvious why that'll
have to be a simplex so
simplisal complex is just a collection
of sets where every subset is in
every subset of a set in the set is in
the collection
so i'm just i'm just representing the
maximal guys on the graph
but not singletons
okay and then we need another concept
which is what we call the canonical dag
so given an mdag like this one here on
the left that we just obtained we can
get the canonical dag by just replacing
any of these bi-directed facets with
an explicit latent variable with the
same children so you can see this graph
here is not the same as the one we
started with
because uh now t does not point into h2
for example and h3 has just disappeared
entirely
but this again has the same marginal
model over
uh the observed variables as this mdac
and then i mean at this point i think
the definition of the marginal model is
pretty obvious
it just means there is you take the m
dag you form its canonical dag you look
at the set of distributions of the
markov with respect to that dag and then
you get rid of the
unobserved variables
and that set is what we define as the
marginal model
so a very simple example if this is the
m-dag so we've just got a bi-directed
edge between x and y it's very similar
to the example i started with um this is
just going to imply
that there's a conditional independence
which you can read off as an m
separation which is
essentially the same as d separation
and there are no other constraints
because again
i can just set
the hidden variable to be y
tell y what to do and x will then learn
what y is
okay any questions at that point
excellent okay so
i'm just now going to outline the proof
strategy
so in one way it's obvious right we know
there are no non-trivial inequalities in
a dag model because the definition is
just made up of a set of equality
constraints so
no work to do there for the other
direction things are a little bit more
technical
so the first thing we're going to do is
show that if we take something called
the maximum arrow projection which i'll
define shortly
that's
it will first of all preserve all the
equality constraints so it has the same
nested model as the original graph
but it will increase the size of the
model so any inequalities
might be removed
so why is that okay well let's think
about this so if we have a counter
example to our conjecture
and we take its maximum arrow projection
then that must also be a counter example
because
if this counter example doesn't have any
inequalities
um
and uh then its maximum area of
projection will also not have any
inequalities and it will just
it will be distributionally equivalent
to the graph we started with
so there's no point in looking at graphs
that are not both maximal and arid
okay
then we'll show
that if there's a non-trivial nested
constraint and that's going to imply
there's non-trivial inequality
okay and then
this is the bit which i think can be
finessed if we understand uh
sort of the the equivalence class of
maximum graphs better which was
something we're working on right now
so then we know that we can just
take the maximum ancestral projection
so this is analogous to the arrow
projection but it's older
and it preserves precisely the
conditional independence structure which
is we know is all the equalities that
can be left
if we know there are no nested
constraints
okay and then we'll show that this also
only removes inequalities and doesn't
potentially introduce any
and then finally
we'll show that if you have a model that
necessarily has a bi-directed edge in it
then it's not equivalent to a dag and
it will also induce a non-trivial
inequality
yes
this question
behind the post
so does this mean that on the way to
proving your main result which is about
the inequalities you've also
characterized bj dmgs or dags
graphically somehow
they're not no okay interesting
i have not done that
so i think that's much harder
right so this is
a proposition i don't expect you to read
all this
but it's going to be useful for proving
that you don't
introduce any inequalities when you take
the maximal arrow projection or the
maximum ancestral projection
and this is originally from
a paper of mine in 2016 since been
extended by ellie and marina ancinelli
but not yet published i think is that
right yeah so
basically the idea is if you have
a bi-directed facet like this one here
w x y and z
in some circumstances you can split it
into two smaller
um facets
so
in this case you can
and what you need is that the the
information that's sort of shared
between the two bits that you're
splitting up
isn't helping you
okay and the reason it's not helping us
in this case is that um y and z
can see
w and x
and they can see all the parents of w
and x value t and s as well
so this guy is not doing anything
and therefore
we don't need to share information this
hidden information between these two
sets of vertices
so i can just replace it with
a good old-fashioned bi-directed edge
between w and x and a separate edge
between y and z and these two models
these two marginal models
are exactly the same
okay
so then
sorry about this miguel i'm going to
need another definition so um the
intrinsic closure of a set is something
i'm going to need to define
so intrinsic closure is just obtained by
alternating between two things
so we take the set
and we look in the graph of all its
ancestors
and then we take the sub graph of that
of just the ancestors
and then we alternate so then we take
the district which is anything you can
reach by one of these red paths
and then you do it again so you then
take the ancestors of that sub graph and
then district within that subgraph and
potentially this can go on you know only
removing one vertex at a time
but fortunately there aren't many
vertices in my graph so it won't take
too long to go through right so what's
the intrinsic closure of y for example
we could start off by taking the
ancestors so in that case that's going
to get rid of z because it's not
an ancestor of y
so we'll just sort of gray that out
then we can look at the district which
you can see is just going to be x and t
so we get rid of w
and that's it right there's nothing else
i can remove because x and t are both
parents of y and
they're all in the same district
okay so the intrinsic closure of y is
the set x t and y
then a second example
we can consider the intrinsic closure of
a pair
so let's suppose we want the intrinsic
closure of y and zed
well again
we could first restrict the ancestors
but that's not going to do anything
because everything is either an ancestor
of y or of zed
then we could look at the district and
that will again get rid of w
but now again we have to stop because
everything is an ancestor still
so um
there's nothing to iterate
okay so the ancestral closure of y zed
as a set is this
set of four variables
okay
and an m dag
is said to be arid if
for every vertex the intrinsic closure
of that just that vertex is itself right
so there's no there's nothing which is
connected to it by these
uh nasty parts like this where
we can't sort of separate uh x and y
because there's a bow
it can be slightly more complicated than
that but um that's i think a good way of
thinking of it
so every singleton vertex needs to be an
intrinsic set
it's its own intrinsic closure
and we then say that arid graph is
maximal
if
every pair of edges with no nested
constraint between them is adjacent
so
i'm not going to
describe in detail when there is and is
not a nested constraint
but
we'll see an example in a second
so
um
here on the left we have a graph which
is not arid that's because the intrinsic
closure of y
is
y and x so it's not it's just itself but
it is maximal because every pair of
vertices is adjacent
on the other hand this is a graph which
is arid but it's not maximal
because as we just saw the intrinsic
closure of y and z in this case is
everything and that is
um bi-directed connected which means
there can be no marginal there can be no
nested constraint between y and z
so this is something called a dense
inducing path
but i don't wish to introduce any more
definitions than i have to
okay so how do we get
we start with some
mdag how do we get the maximum arrow
projection
so this is going to be slightly
different definition from the one that
thomas nelia probably know
but it is equivalent
so the first thing we do we just take
the graph
and then we add
directed edges
if we need to from any vertex which is a
parent of anything in the intrinsic
closure
into the vertex
and then we go through all the
non-adjacent pairs
and check whether or not their intrinsic
the intrinsic closure of that pair is
bi-directly connected and if it is we
add in a bi-directed edge
and then finally
we go through and then remove any
bi-directed edges that are in bows ie
where there's already a directed edge so
if you have two edges between a vertex
you need to get rid of the bi-direction
one as the last step
okay so
here's an example
so this is the same as the graph i was
looking at a sort of combination of the
graph i was looking at earlier so
the first thing we need to do is note
that the intrinsic closure of y is y x t
which we calculated before and therefore
um any parents of those guys need to
also be directed into y
so in this case
w is a parent of x and therefore we need
to add this directed edge
here okay
then we might notice that
y and z
have an intrinsic closure which is
bi-director connected so we need to add
this bi-directed edge down here
and then that we've done the first two
phases now there's only one edge to add
in each case and then we need to remove
any bi-directed edges which um are where
there's already a directed edge so we
just get rid of that by directed edge
there
so we'll gray that out and then this
model is the maximum arrow projection of
this graph on the left
okay and then this is where
that useful result comes in because now
we can see that sorry a quick question
is it unique
so because yes okay
yes yeah so we you can check in our
paper that
no matter what order you do things then
you always get the same result
good so that now now this is where our
useful position comes in because um when
i remove
this bi-directed edge you can see that
the parents of of x
which are w
is also a parent of y and x itself as a
parent of y and the only other
bi-directed facet involving x um has
only t as a child which is also a parent
of y so there's nothing to worry about
when we remove this edge we will not
introduce any new inequalities
okay
so
we know that taking the maximum
projection won't change nested
constraints
but it might it might reduce the number
of inequalities but that's fine because
we know if g is a counter example to
result
then so is g dagger the maximum
ancestral projection of g
so in other words we can just choose to
consider only maximal arid graphs
and if if there is a counter example
which there isn't
then uh we know that we will find it in
that set
okay
so now
um this is the bit that i would sort of
suggest that we could probably
avoid doing if we understood um
the sort of
equivalence class of
nested models a bit better but we still
don't so for the moment this is how to
do it
so if there's a non-trivial nested
constraint that means that there's some
vertex you can fix
so in this case it's t
and a new m separation will appear
that's the definition
so this can only happen if the graph
isn't ancestral which means we have
in this case we have this vertex y
it has an ancestor x but it's also
joined to x by a single bi-directed edge
so that's a graph which is not ancestral
and the point is then we can fix t
and a path
that was um open conditional on y before
it comes closed because
there's no collider there anymore right
so sorry there is a collider but it's no
longer an ancestor of y
so this means that
w becomes d separated from y if you
don't condition on anything
um and
basically um we can show that for any
maximum arid graph with a non-trivial
nested constraint there is also
a non-trivial inequality
so i think this is quite an interesting
result because we've sort of known
for a while that
um
these maxima graphs have the same
dimension as the marginal model but we
haven't known whether there are any that
achieve
the boundary
okay and we know now that if it has a
nested constraint then it doesn't
achieve the boundary and there is some
gap
that may have may not be of interest to
quantum physicists
but it sort of gives you different
models that you can try right you can
say okay well maybe there's an equality
which is
quantum viable
in this set of inequalities
okay
so a very sketch of why uh nested
constraints will induce inequalities
so um
in order for there to be an estimate
constraint you have to have two vertices
that are in the same district that's in
this case that's x and y
and some vertex that's in between them
which we'll call c that you can fix
and um it can't be in the same district
as x and y otherwise it wouldn't be
fixable
and then the point is
that will induce some new m separation
and
generically it seems that you'll only
get a completely new independence in one
of these three cases
so here i'm going to fix x skin w here
i'm going to fix t given x and here i'm
also going to fix x given w
so in this case
the two children of x which i fixed
become independent given x
and so in general it could be
descendants
in this case uh
it's that the this descendant of t
becomes independent of a parent of x
after we do the fixing
and in this case the guy that we fixed
becomes independent of one of its
descendants given some other guy in
between
um and they these seem to be the only
cases that you can get
apart from a slightly more complicated
example which i'm not going to introduce
right now okay
so
in all yeah and the key is that in all
three of these
graphs
there is an inequality constraint right
so
this one you all know
spells inequality uh this one you get
via an e separation which again beater
mentioned earlier so we just delete the
node t
and we'll get this new
joint conditional independence between x
and w and y
and here uh this is a graph that ellie
calls the ghost and uh he's shown that
this also has an inequality in it
okay
so
then
i'll sort of skip over this a bit
because it's basically the same
as uh
the result i've already shown you
we just do the same thing now we take
the maximum ancestral projection
and we'll show that that
only makes the model bigger but it
preserves all the conditional
independences
and therefore any counter-example
to the conjecture that is not maximal
ancestral um but doesn't well
and obviously it can't have any nested
constraints will have its maximum
ancestral graph also as a counter
example
so maximum in this case just means that
any pair of edges that aren't adjacent
can be m separated by some other set of
the observed variables
an ancestral already defined it just
means you can't be a joined by by
director just to one of your own
ancestors
okay and then
again very quickly running through this
so
the first thing you need to do is to add
edges
from
uh
so you consider pairs that can't be m
separated in the graph this is how you
make sure it's maximal and if um
if one of them is an ancestor of the
other then you add a directed edge and
if it's not then you add a bi-directed
edge
and then finally you remove any
bi-directed edges between edges between
nodes that are already adjacent
and again this isn't the way it was
defined but it ensures that when i do
this i can apply my proposition again
and know that it's not going to change
the marginal model that i
have created by adding these edges
okay so here's a very brief example this
is a this is the the verma graph we saw
before
but i've added this edge w to y now so
it only has
the d separation between w and t
so i'm going to add an edge from x to y
because um
they can't be m separated and v is an
ancestor sorry and x is an ancestor of y
and then
i'm not going to add any bi-directed
edges in this case
but then when i remove edges i'm going
to delete this bi-directed edge because
there's already a directed edge there
so and i know that that's safe because
of my proposition earlier
okay so
why a mag sufficient well this is
basically the same slide as we saw
before for marge's um if we know there's
no trivial nested constraint
then we can just project and we know
we've just seen
that you'll only make the model bigger
and you'll preserve all the equality
constraints
so now we just need to consider max
okay and then what we do is we look at
the equivalence class
of
a set of mags
and it's not equivalent to a dag
if and only if there's an edge which is
always bidirected
in one in every single one of those
graphs
okay
if that happens there can be two reasons
for it
so the first is that we have a graph
like this
where both
end points of the bi-directed edge are
involved in an unshielded collider
okay and this
we know how to deal with because it's
the bell graph right so
we know that this does induce an
inequality
and on the right hand side here is the
alternative which is what's called a
discriminating path
so it enables you to know that this
is a collider
even though it's uh
not
um unshielded right so there's there's
this pair xt but it does have an edge
between it so you can't just immediately
read off that they are
this is a collider but because of the
the pattern of the other edges you can
um and these are the only two situations
in which you will get a bi-directed edge
yeah
so i mean
so in a pack
so i'm trying not to introduce packs
because again so many definitions but
basically in a pack you can always
choose to orient all the edges which
could be directed as being directed
and therefore the only ones that are
left
are just the bi-directive ones that you
started with
so that was what i meant by that
in the entire class of
mags which are ordinary markers into g
there's just a bi-directed edge between
some pair in all of those max no so
there is a specific pair that will have
a bidirectional edge between it in every
graph
so like in this in this case for example
it's clear that it must be because this
has to be a collider and this has to be
a collider
and therefore any graph that is markov
equivalent to this will also have these
both as colliders and therefore this
edge must be bidirected
good question
um
okay and then
yeah so this is just sort of you have
five minutes yeah five minutes okay
perfect um so we know that if you have a
four chain of vertices with two
unshielded colliders in it then it's
going to induce inequalities this is the
bell graph
this is the bell graph if you condition
on w and x
and this um
so you can well there's different things
you could do right you could sort of
condition on w
and you'll end up with the triangle
scenario which again we know induces
inequalities
okay
and for the discriminating parts what's
interesting it doesn't matter how long
the discriminating path is
um we can just use e-separation to show
there's a constraint
so here we just delete x and here we
delete x and t
and if we had you know a discriminating
path of length k we would just delete
k minus three of the intermediate nodes
um was it k minus two i get confused but
um
yeah so so we just delete these guys and
then we find that there's an e
separation and you know it's non-trivial
because
uh this
was not a d separation in the original
graph right so um if i
condition on x
then i'm going to be dependent on z
but if i don't condition on x i'm going
to be dependent on y so i can't have
both of them jointly
so that shows that it's a non-trivial
inequality that you get in addition
to equality constraints
okay so now we're done we've shown that
if a graph is a counter example to the
claim then says it's maximum added
closure
if it has a non-trivial nested
constraint then it induces an inequality
if it doesn't have a nested constraint
then
another counter example will be the
maximum ancestral closure of that graph
and if one of these graphs has a
definite bi-directed edge then we show
that that will also induce
an inequality constraint
and then we're done right so any graph
that is not
markov equivalent to a dag will fail at
one of these stages
so
briefly
so what i've tried to do is
introduce this proof which may be of
little interest beyond um
for proving things like equivalence
which is something that does interest me
um
i sort of tried to introduce some ideas
which might be of interest to people
right so maximum error projection i'd
say is a very useful concept and i've
shown in another paper that for example
if you have a graph which is not maximal
or not arid
then there's always a pair sorry it's
not maximal i should say is there's
always a pair of vertices that aren't
adjacent that you can make
identically equal
and have all the other variables be
independent of them
so if you imagine trying to do
causal search with that
you just conclude that these two guys
are adjacent and everything else is is
totally irrelevant whereas actually the
the structure you have to use is is much
more complicated than that
so
um
there's something very nice about max
mario projection because it's precisely
the set of graphs where that cannot
happen
um i've also introduced nested
constraints
then maximum ancestral projection and
discriminating paths so that's sort of a
way of orienting um
extra edges in a in a mag
and then i've sort of introduced
e-separation although um
i guess uh vrt did that for me earlier
today
and as i say i think you could
significantly simplify this proof if we
understood the nested peg better so then
we could just say okay we've got a
maximal area graph
and then hopefully there'll be a result
which is similar where we say okay if it
has
a bi-directed edge in every graph then
the edge will be bidirected in the
nested pack
and if we don't then it's going to be
markov equivalent to a dag
okay
and then we'll be able to skip the
ancestral projection part entirely
thanks very much
i asked my question can you hear me
yeah
really nice talk thank you uh i i just
was wondering in your proof sketch
at some point you said there's you know
generically three cases that give you a
new independence yeah
um and so should i understand that as
this is kind of a
classification of all non-trivial nested
constraints that it always boils down to
these
three structures
so it's that's not quite true um because
you can get this uh tricky example which
i have prepared some slides on
so i sorry i can't see your slides very
well from
a video of the room but
uh okay so
can we
sort of
get back to
yeah if it's like switch it to uh
just showing the slides on the zoom that
would be great ah thank you yes it's
done excellent okay so so this is a
graph where you get something a little
bit different
and what's interesting about this is
that um
this is also a mac model right so
um
and therefore you would think
maybe the constraints are just the same
um and what you see is it is a mag
because uh for example w is marginally
independent of z so there's a constraint
there
um and it's conditionally independent of
t and y given x and w and x
conditionally independent of y and t and
so on so it's a maximal graph
but
it turns out there is a nested
constraint
which is something that surprised
thomas
because if you fix t
now you get a joint
constraint between w
and z and y given t you just marginalize
x and then no information can flow
between them
so this is a sort of separate case which
i
uh slid under the radar in some sense um
but you can see
in this case you get a five chain so
it's even
there are even more obviously
inequalities in this case
um
but yes i think that for entirely new
independences
yes independences so that are revealed
by fixing
these are the only three
sort of generic cases
that's really interesting because it
suggests a kind of classification you
know by your theorem of where you expect
to see inequalities
okay
just just to be clear that's
you have to go you may have to go
many levels down it's not really
necessarily after one fixing yes yeah
absolutely so um so this is just you
just think of these as cartoons right so
there might be loads of other vertices
that we've already fixed that i just
haven't drawn on
and of course there will be you know in
general
um
this could be um a whole path
of vertices from t to y and from w to x
and that's also fine
great exciting stuff thanks
more questions
so maybe related to this so after a
number of fixing you go to this
structure and you can show there is
inequality
does that apply there is inequality in
the original distribution just by
yes so if you think about the nested
model
there's no inequality right you just you
just get the independence
whereas this is clearly giving you
something extra because it's on this
final structure which you would not get
unless it were
an additional thing yeah i'm just a bit
worried because those things are on the
margins
right but but the point is in the nested
model
you've got to some factor where there is
no inequality
all the fixings you do will not induce
any inequalities directly
so just to be clear the nested model is
that sort of by true by definition
because nested models being defined by
the constraints exactly yeah so it's
defined by the independences you get by
doing fixings yeah i'm just a bit
worried because in the dac if you just
look at a specific margin there could be
equal inequalities but you would call
them as trivial inequalities sure but
the point is in it you know if if we're
doing this in a dag you would never you
you could you can fix anything
and you never induce any inequalities
because all you do is add independences
right and so if you're doing valid
fixings in the nested model all you ever
do is either nothing you just introduce
trivial inequalities because you're
fixed
or
you get some new
m separation and that's the definition
of the model
okay
some more questions
let's run the two speakers
[Applause]